the temperate Waters off the Guyana
Coast cover some of the world's largest
reserves of crude oil but it's not the
oil president Irfan Ali is interested in
it's what he can do with it the story
about Guyana is not oil and gas
we are a country that is rich in history
we're a country that will be and mark my
words
will be a leader
and food security and Agriculture and
importantly we will be among the best
ecotourism destination you can find
and that oil Revenue may help you get
there that's all revenue will help us to
get there faster guyana's sprawling
starbrook oil field holds an estimated
11 billion barrels of crude enough to
turn one of South America's poorest
countries into one of the richest and
contractor Exxon Mobil has discovered
two more deposits just this past week
making that field even bigger it's big
on an international scale a global scale
as far as the conventional oil and gas
resources being found around the world
in the last seven eight years
but also at a national level this is
transformative for the country for
Guyana critics in the opposition party
warn of the so-called resource curse
that struck other oil-rich nations it's
where some benefit greatly While most
miss out stock market has gone up in
only a few years 400 percent
but the minimum wage has only gone up 36
percent in the same time period And so
you've seen a huge escalation in terms
of inequality
some 40 percent of Guyanese live in
poverty earning below five and a half
dollars a day according to the World
Bank the influx of oil money has raised
rents along with the height of buildings
in the capital of Georgetown center of
the petroleum boom
the infrastructure here in Georgetown
has been growing by the day and for good
reason since oil was discovered here in
2015 one-third of all the new oil found
in the world has been off the Guyana
Coast
only a decade ago georgetown's Demerara
River was a sleepy port
today it's a hive of activity as oil
service vessels Shuffle back and forth
to Offshore rigs the world is trying to
move away from oil
do you feel at all like you're in a Race
Against Time here yes it's a Race
Against Time it must be done responsibly
though in a sustainable way but we
intend to accelerate the production
speeding up production might help this
generation Prosper while creating a base
for the next John hendron Al Jazeera
Georgetown Guyana